when you sign on to direct a TV show how
much prep time are you giving
contractually I think they have to give
me the script 24 hours before shooting
starts so that's not a lot really and it
has to do with that with the fact that I
am not expected to have creative input
into development and into the script at
all I'm being hired to direct what's on
the page I would say in in real terms of
that plays out I usually have about a
week I would say and that's when I score
on the screenwriting background so I
have opinions on the script for better
or for worse and whether I'm right or
not as a different thing but I have the
feeling I'm kind of failing this is this
episode if I'm not voicing my
suggestions which I'll just write up
sent to the showrunner and whatever of
that they want to incorporate great
whatever they don't want to incorporate
great that's the only time I ever
suggest that in the writing stage
because then I have the feeling I've
done my work I've contributed my filter
as the audience reading it fresh
basically which i think is important for
them to know because I hired me as a
director so to hear about my filter and
my feelings and my maybe red flags where
I feel like this or that will be hard to
bring out the way that I think they
wanted I'd say that once and whatever
they reject I know that they've already
worked on it so long and so many people
had to give their okay to greenlight it
that I can't come in and change
everything but that ship has sailed
you know and that was something that
took some getting used to doing TV at
first and then I go in the time that I
have depending on how much time I have
to sit with it I'm going through every
single scene and I have this kind of
questionnaire of 36 questions that I ask
myself for every scene so that because
because when I first did I didn't have
it written down it was kind of a
whatever question I could think of that
I would would consider with the scene I
did in so much time
was wasted on remembering the questions
that at some point I was like I just and
I'd like a simplified one for TV with I
think 17 questions or something and now
we're just gonna tick them off Bowman
Bowman bomb answer them and to me the
great thing is that with some questions
if you force yourself to answer like
there would be something like in what
way does the lighting inform the mood in
the scene who's who's seen is it it
through whose eyes do we see things what
is the one takeaway that the audience
has to understand the terms of
information what is the one visual image
that I wanted to carry away all those
things and some some questions don't
seem to apply at all at first and if you
force yourself to still think of an
answer they are always the most fruitful
ones because you suddenly realize how it
applies big time like one one question
would be for example if you run
completely out of time how do you cover
the scene in the shortest amount of time
and just knowing that that I have that
in my back pocket gives me a lot of
security on set because I know if all
our there's this saying it's I'll put
sure that saying if your essay its
Citizen Kane in the morning and it's the
Duke of hazards and yeah which is so
true like you come in the morning do you
have Holland we do this in this and then
at the end of the day it's just like
somehow get the stuff in camera that we
have that scene so when that kicks in I
want to be prepared for that I don't
hope for that to happen but I want to be
prepared or if you wanted to shoot the
entire scene in one take how would you
do that or which how do you want to
shoot the scene and if you were forced
to do it another way what would you do
and just by forcing yourself into oh
that would be a what if they might go to
way of shooting this those are the
images that come to mind in the very
beginning instinctively but if I force
myself to put a pin in that and come up
with an alternative way for whatever
reason there is it the more resistance I
have to that the more interesting stuff
comes out of the answer to the
question that's all a very long-winded
say their way of saying preparing for
that stuff but I'll do that with the
with the scenes that seemed most
important and then the way I structured
which has served me well is that I don't
start preparing scenes with scene one
and then go through but I start
preparing scenes depending prioritizing
them by which scene needs the most
answers in terms of physical stuff
because I know that as soon as I come
wherever we're shooting the prop master
will ants want answers that productions
animals answers everybody who has to
make something that she realized needs
some time it's a prep time to do that
right so if there's a scene that has
let's say there is the book of the dead
the magical book of the dead right it
would be I know that the second that
prop master comes up to me the clock is
ticking for him or her to get me the
best possible version of this book of
the Dead so every day that I go like oh
I haven't thought about that give me a
day the quality of that book will be
reduced and put that person under more
stress whereas if I can immediately give
them an answer and go like this is how I
picture that ba ba ba ba bum boom they
have more time to work on it I get the
better result right so in the beginning
when I first was preparing episodes I
was kind of preparing the most character
intensive ones first because they felt
the most important storytelling was but
that was exactly the wrong way to go
because the character stuff is stuff
that doesn't have physical component to
it that has to materialize I can still
rehearse with the actors pretty short
notice they don't need to know a week in
advance that I'm looking for a certain
character a moment that is pretty it
seems important in the story but in the
physical nature of the overall thing
it's not and then I just write knowing
that other people need time to think
about stuff too I write down the
questions that I want to answer that
that I want to ask certain departments
and that I want to ask
first of all the showrunner because I
don't want to work for a week and then I
have the meeting with the showrunner and
I realized that they had a completely
different approach or a different look
or whatever whatever so I need my basic
basic answers to know what our playing
field is to realize this episode of
course I've watched the ideally all the
episodes that are leading up to my
episode so that I understand that the
language of the show at the look of the
show and all that at the the one case
where I wasn't able to do it was my
field of Walking Dead episode where I
had it was very short notice and I had
watched the first season but then didn't
watch all the episodes leading up to
mine but I was like I'll get away with
it they will react respond now and they
immediately knew like there was over one
or two conversations and they
immediately know you haven't watched the
last because you are asking me to do
stuff that I have done last episode yeah
so I'll never pretend again I'll just
say I'm sorry I didn't watch the last
episode so but if I can obviously watch
the whole build-up to it which in
reality obviously you only get so far
until you hit episodes that haven't that
are not out yet so when you try to get
the scripts for those episodes read the
scripts you try if you can get the rough
cut which sometimes already exists off
the episode before you're talking more
information you can get about the
lead-up into your show I think the
better and then I always try to meet
every actor one-on-one because you're so
little time to build a rapport with
actors in TV that even if you have ten
minutes with them by yourself they are
forced to form a relationship with you
whereas if you do that with three people
in the room sometimes the producer wants
to be there and I'm always saying don't
don't take this personally but I'd
rather do it on my own yeah because a
group dynamic is something that will
happen quickly enough but on set you do
need the relationship with each actor on
a private level as much as possible that
was a very long answer
what if you only have 24 hours to
prepare all of that prep work watching
episodes reading scripts all of that
stuff sounds wonderful
but if you're giving it 24 hours in
advance that's got to be really scary
because now you've got to choose what's
most important that I do right I've
never had it in real life luckily that I
had only 24 hours but that is the DGA
mandated minimum I think I might could
shortest was one week
I mean you then cut corners you watch on
YouTube you watch the recap for the
episodes the two minutes and what
happened now you read the Wikipedia
episode entries that tell you what
happened in so that you at least have
the story arc down you watch the pilot
for sure you maybe watch if there's any
behind-the-scenes footage where the
producers are talking that's worth
watching on YouTube because you get a
feel for what kind of people they are
and then going through the script you
would probably reduce your your
character stuff to what does the
character want in this scene where are
they starting out where are they ending
up what's their want because if it's
like that is the minimum of what you
need to know going into a scene working
with an actor they've they're they're
wanted that every person in this scene
has an objective what is that and if you
have that then you can probably walk in
especially with TV where everybody has
played their characters for a while and
knows their character better than you do
you're probably okay walking into that
yeah in terms of the the physical stuff
it's it's probably worth trying to
communicate with the departments already
and don't wait until the producers
introduce you to the prop master because
that might be days and days and days
later but try to be like proactively but
an email to the productions I can I have
the email address of the costume
designer of the above the prop master
email them directly and tell them what
you want you know start conversation
with them because every minute counts in
the end everything is so stressful that
if you
can get a head start by a day or two it
makes it everything much much easier
much more doable 36 questions that you
have
do you literally have them typed out no
that's right I've done less and less now
I would say maybe I'm doing 20 no
absolutely because you just get it takes
a while like for a movie I would still
do that if I know I have one year before
I'm shooting I would still do 36
questions for and I would storyboard
every scene because I always have the
feeling if life that the main goal of
this whole of the questionnaire is to
force yourself to spend 10 minutes
inside of that scene whichever way just
be there with the scene think of nothing
else other than this scene so that when
you do it on set it feels like territory
that you've stood in once before that's
not the person I'm now thinking about it
but it's like and that's why I'm
storyboarding stuff
I can't storyboard it all looks terrible
no one can't decipher my storyboards
doesn't matter that's not what it's
about and I'm not going to shoot the
storyboards it's just a method to force
myself to intensely think about the
scene for a second
if you always come up with something
it's not that I think Nick Cave said
that that about his muse and whatever he
said that the only job that he has is to
show up at 9 o'clock in the morning and
sit at the piano and don't leave until 4
o'clock in the afternoon that's the only
pressure he feels that's his entire job
and whatever happens at that time
happens and with this preparation
process I have that feeling if at first
you can't like are not going to come up
with anything in every scene look spend
now it's two people walking down the
street there is no subtext what am I
even doing you but two minutes later
just sitting there you go like oh my god
this is a metaphor for his walk to the
gallows and if I shoot it probably yeah
just through sheer I guess boredom or
something to sit with that you always
come up with something interesting and
in TV or everywhere maybe I always have
the feeling if I find one thing that
interests me about the scene one thing
that where I get up in the morning and
go like oh today I want to do that I'm
looking forward to that I have to find
that in this scene where they are
walking down the street
and you always find you know and that
one interesting thing always also most
of the time informs the one direction
that you give your team because the last
thing that a team wants obviously is for
you to do a big speech 15 minutes long
in the morning about how you see the
scene how the scene reminds you of your
mother ba ba ba ba ba if the but if you
can give one direction where it's like
let us treat this letter then the
character is put on the table as if it's
nuclear waste that's how I wanted to
shop that's how I want every pop up a
Papa it's the s if thing it's an act
receptor to me once I asked her what is
she looking for in a standard direction
and she said a code word a key basically
to open up whatever that opens up which
to me like changed everything because it
was a because before that I was that
person would kind of give these big
speeches that I had thought about before
tava helped no one because no one can
process all that but since I know that
that unlocking key thing that's really
what it is because now everybody can
make their decisions in in connection
with this one thing that I put out there
and it changes everything changed
everybody's approach to Z and suddenly a
scene is not generic anymore because
here's the big problem
Fincher I think said that it's not
directing it's not about what all you do
it's about what you not do and that's
how you define style which is true it's
so intimidating to think here's a scene
and you could shoot it whichever way
from wherever which with whatever lens
Bom Bom Bom
how do you make decisions and I think
there are a lot of Directors or
beginning directors get completely lost
in there guy I don't know so if you find
one thing that you base it on it anchors
everything and it informs most of your
answers some things about have any
effect on but whether I put the camera
here with the letter and the foreground
or over here without the letters
suddenly there will be an answer to it
because I know that this letter is
important and I want to treat it like a
dangerous nuclear-waste artifact so I
should it different so this I think this
one as if thing I would if I only had 24
hours I would try to find that forever
scene find the want of each character it
will be stressful 24 hours to do that
but that would kind of be the minimum
preparation that you probably would want
to do and when you talked about the fear
of the blank page with screenwriting it
sounds like there's a similar thing with
sorry part right I'll see now you aren't
there so there would be such a thing as
directors block which would be exactly
that you can do anything so what do you
do it's the same as the blank page I
just invented this story this bedtime
story book because I can't tell bedtime
stories if you said tell me a story and
there's a prince
I don't yeah it I just talked to a
friend yesterday and he said what he
does is he is asking their child for
three words and then he will tell a
story so if the child says toilet-bowl
tiger and bracelet then he's suddenly
out of infinite options of what to tell
has zeroed in on three things that he
will not connect to something and make
work somehow which to me was genius
which was but I was trying to do with
that book and much more complicated he
really distilled it down to something
very simple but I think it's the same
it's the same with finding that one the
approach to the scene if there's all
this language around it then is so
intimidating and scary where people are
like oh I want to hear your vision of
the production designer goes what's
what's your vision for this and secretly
got I don't have a vision but you can
say I don't have a vision but I think
that's important not to be intimidated
by but they just want that one word the
key - how are they supposed to approach
this thing and if you just give them one
that it's like this place has to feel
really lived in or he hasn't tied it up
in two weeks it opens a whole different
door for them and third apartment you
know or you want if you talk to the
cinematographer you really want to feel
the presence of his dead parents by the
shadows on the wall into the
cinematographer it immediately means aha
so we have to we need light sources that
are low so that the
shadows are being thrown up on the wall
so now that cinematographer has to talk
to production design to get those lamps
and motivate those it's a whole chain of
events but you have now given them the
direction that they can work inside of
their department and with other
departments without your constant input
and then you just have to you have to
trust that you're working with good
people that know what they're doing
where you don't have to micromanage
where exactly that lamp has to stand but
you know what the effect is that you got
and the effect you're going for is and
that goes full circle talked about
earlier they are going back to what do
you want the audience to experience you
know maybe it helps if you know do you
want the audience to feel comfortable in
the space of the protagonist or do you
wanted to feel spooky or do you want it
to feel sterile or deep bapupa
because it means something else for
every department but once you figure out
that one word comfortable or sterile or
bappa everybody knows what to do with it
but before you give them that one code
word they don't know which direction to
work it with TV it's a little bit
different again because that world has
already been established and they
already know the vocabulary of the world
and they kind of already know those
answers but if you are doing a movie
where that world only has to be you know
created that's where that is vital I
know from just doing background work
like 15 years ago that some sets moved
very fast like I can remember being on
ER and I mean the way I mean I was like
I'm supposed to walk and do my crawl I
could I couldn't keep up whereas other
sets were slower it seemed like ER was
almost like this circular motion that
they had everybody kind of moved they
moved the camera in and they're going
around this one room where everyone's in
these hospital beds and you're either an
orderly or whatever and the pace of that
set was incredibly fast everybody knew
their role oh and they had pretty much
designated regular extras and I was just
like a filling and I didn't know which
way was which where's other ones it was
had been established just very recently
and you know you're sitting in a church
pew crying or whatever and it was just a
slower thing right so it's just
interesting how certain sets and the
dynamic
of the scene or the sets or the show is
just a faster pace right well that I
think has to do with has that set been
established they shot 500 episodes in
there they don't have to figure out how
to shoot that set every time a new but
there's like you know a kind of process
whereas if it's a church that we have
we're shooting in for the first time you
do have to figure out these all these
things which lens does that way of the
church look the best bubble but it's all
trial and error whereas with the set
that you've shot on again and again the
trial and error phase is over and you're
just going to go right to the to the
effect right with the actors and pulling
them aside I find them very interesting
because you're right that people behave
differently with other people around and
then was that something that you've
heard other directors do that they they
like to speak to the actor one-on-one
without the handlers or whatever around
because people will receive your message
differently and they'll be yeah I
haven't talked to other directors about
it but I know that some productions ask
me do you want to meet them before so so
I know that it must be a known thing out
there that some directors want to do
that and I'm sure that every director
uses that time differently because I in
the beginning was like oh I'm gonna go
through the script with them and we're
gonna analyze Papa Papa by now it's
mostly we're talking about their pets or
my pets or whatever you know it's really
not even about that we that we sit over
the material together but really just
about that we spend one moment together
where neither of us are pretending and
playing for a bigger audience but it's
really just us in the moment if you
always go back to that initial
connection that that you have I think
that's like the best spend twenty
minutes of an entire shoot is that a
long time and no matter what you do
that's great yeah playing for an
audience that's really that's really
interesting yeah I think it works the
same in interviews as well when there's
less people around but you get a much
different vibe than if you do a junket
and people don't see that there's ten
people in the room but and it is a
different feeling yeah
you